a lot of marketers and sales people like  to talk about the internal thoughts that  someone has like first they need  awareness and then they need blah blah  they reverse engineer fictitious steps  of someone's mental thought process when  they have no evidence to support what  someone's thinking it's not useful what  are the things that are useful these are  the things that are observable that we  can drive action towards that we create  an outcome and then we have a feedback  loop we have those things then we can  move the variables and get closer to  where we're trying to go and the  feelings although I recognize that they  exist they're not helpful in trying to  edit what our activities are